i'm so glad to introduce you to makeup
instagram god it's me and chan
hi everyone it's me and i am back for
another colorful makeup tutorial
this time with the theme of a kind of
night out
look
starting off
i'm actually going to go in first with
the tinted sunscreen and this is how
much you should use for your face and
neck
so this sunscreen is pretty sheer it
doesn't give a lot of coverage which is
actually what i like about tinted
sunscreens is that they kind of give an
evening out of texture and tone they
provide a nice
layer
of just a little something something
there and then i'll go in with a little
bit of concealer
i also really enjoy applying my
sunscreens some of my concealers with
fingers these days because i find that
they really push the product into the
skin and make it look very natural
going in with just a little bit of blush
again i don't want anything that's going
to add like texture to my skin something
like a very thin layer
going in with some some strategic powder
really where i get oily i want to
minimize
the product
rubbing off
and then i usually honestly these days
skip highlighter because my skin gets so
oily
that i don't really need it so i'm gonna
move on to the eyes
all right so i am gonna go in with a
little bit of eyelid primer
to start off i'm going to go in with my
hip dot palette this is the
diamond diva palette this is a clean
fluffy brush into this really pretty
pastel pink shade
taking that and sweeping that into the
crease i'm really just going for a wash
of pink color here because the the real
star of this look is rhinestones but i'm
creating this base because if you don't
feel like you want to do the rhinestones
you could easily just do a nice pink eye
with a little bit a little bit of liner
and that's still fun too
now i'm going to go in with classic cat
eye you've seen me do it a couple of
times now so i won't i'll kind of speed
through it
[Music]
all right so that's the eyeliner done
i'm gonna go in with classic you know
mascara bring the look together
[Music]
this is a tweezerman eyelash curler and
it is a great very affordable eyelash
curler i like to do
a method of kind of getting your
eyelashes and then pumping at the base
and then all the way to the root of your
lashes to get the best
curl
this is some waterproof mascara which i
find if you have very stick straight
eyelashes waterproof is the best to hold
a curl it's almost like hairspray
[Music]
you can easily stop here this is a very
very fun look i love a pink eye with a
little red lip or a matching pink lip is
a beautiful look but knowing me
i like color i'm gonna go in with
some rhyme styles grabbing a
tweezer i find this is the easiest way
to apply them i'm gonna do a kind of
like little rainbow above my lash line
[Music]
and that's the floating crease
same on the other side
[Music]
but what's great is that once they're on
and you wear them they stay on pretty
well when you remove them i would just
say remove them with a tweezer run them
in like a little like a solution of dish
soap and water let them dry and then you
can actually reapply them and reuse them
with a little bit of eyelash glue to
adhere them as long as you want really
so i think the eyes are pretty intense
i'm going to keep it pretty neutral on
the lips but again
this look would also look good with red
lipstick with with like magenta lipstick
it's really up to you it's your
playground
[Music]
so this is it you can adapt it however
you want and i hope you enjoyed it and
see you next time bye